[Música]
el viaje a marte la última frontera del
planeta rojo
nuestro nuevo hogar
marcianos
cuando nosotros miramos a marte y sobre
todo recientemente con películas
taquilleras de hollywood hemos retomado
ciertos nuevos ideales y ciertas nuevas
fronteras
y tal vez esa poco un poco difícil el
poder justificar el esfuerzo y sobre
todo el dinero y los recursos no
solamente humanos sino económicos que se
requieren para viajar a este planeta
y ustedes podrán imaginarse todos estos
recursos que se necesiten
y ciertamente aquí en la tierra en
países como méjico y muchos otros
tenemos muchas comunidades que requieren
salud requieren recursos básicos
educación y muchas otras cosas que a
veces nosotros como las tenemos no
pensamos en lo afortunados que somos de
tenerlas
y ciertamente muchas veces me hacen esta
pregunta de para qué ir a marte si
tenemos tantos problemas en la tierra no
es mejor primero resolver estos
problemas y después ir a marte y el día
de hoy les voy a presentar tres
probables respuestas para esto
la primera es la realización de un sueño
increíble imaginen que un día se
despiertan en marte imaginen que viven
en mar te despiertan miren el cielo
estrellado y una de las estrellas es la
tierra no es una estrella más sino es la
tierra ustedes están en marte y la
estrella es la tierra tal vez sus papás
o alguien más está allá en ese planeta
que lo ven ustedes tan lejano como una
estrella
imaginen un día ver en la televisión un
astronauta abriendo la cápsula de
aterrizaje en marte
y saliendo de la cápsula y poniendo el
pie en el tierra marciano y marcando por
primera vez que como humanidad todos
juntos logramos el gran martes
cuando fuimos a la luna en los años 60
el esfuerzo para lograr ese gran hito de
la historia no solamente fue
un grupo de personas y nos fueron
aproximadamente 500.000 personas
trabajando juntas por un esfuerzo común
500 mil personas medio millón de
personas aproximadamente la población de
ciudad obregón imagínense toda la
población de ciudad obregón trabajando
por un objetivo único
los que vivían en esa época o los que
todavía viven y recuerdan el alunizaje
muchos recuerdan justamente dónde
estaban que estaban haciendo en ese
momento en específico y es algo que
recuerdan por toda su vida muy
probablemente nosotros nos tocará vivir
el mismo momento cuando aterrizamos en
marte
y lo recordaremos como nuestro gran paso
para la humanidad y lo recordemos de
nuevo como un esfuerzo tan increíble
puede juntarnos a todos sin importar de
donde vengamos de qué país seamos si no
podemos trabajar para un objetivo que no
representa países no representa razas no
representa idiomas no representa ninguna
otra más cosa más que la grandeza de la
humanidad y el convertirnos en una
especie interplanetario
hasta donde sabemos la primera especie y
podremos entonces decidir si queremos
vivir en otro planeta o queremos vivir
aquí
la estación espacial internacional que
mientras estamos nosotros aquí en ciudad
obregón le está dando vuelta
a la tierra más o menos cada 90 minutos
tiene astronautas de todo el mundo y
este es un ejemplo perfecto de cómo se
puede pasar más allá de las fronteras de
los países de los problemas políticos y
de hecho podemos estar todos juntos
trabajando con un objetivo común
y retomando lo que platicaba de la luna
cuando vayamos a marte este vaso un
esfuerzo completamente diferente
marte esta distancia es que ni siquiera
nos podemos imaginar
cuando hablamos de la luna estamos
hablando de cientos de miles de millas
que si ciertamente es una distancia
gigantesca pero tal vez lo podemos
imaginar un poco más fácil cuando
vayamos a marte vamos a estar hablando
de cientos de millones de millas es una
distancia que ni siquiera nos lo podemos
imaginar nuestra mente no nos permite
imaginarnos lo grande de esta distancia
otro problema son las comunicaciones
nosotros vivimos en un mundo donde
podemos comunicarnos en tiempo real con
prácticamente cualquier persona del
mundo podemos levantar nuestro teléfono
celular podemos saber nuestra
computadora y podemos hablar con alguien
al otro lado del mundo en cualquier
momento y lo tomamos como algo cotidiano
en el mundo y así estamos acostumbrados
a vivir sin embargo cuando vayamos a
marte
las distancias tan largas hacen que las
comunicaciones se alargan por la misma
manera y estamos hablando de hasta 20
minutos o 30 minutos en comunicaciones
de doble vía es decir imaginen que
ustedes viven
en marte que sus papás y bebiendo en la
tierra quieren hablarles en la mañana
para preguntar cómo están levantan el
teléfono o la mamá con éstas
se van a hacer otra cosa 15 minutos
regresan y escuchan a su mamá bien y tú
este es algo que este es un paradigma
que tenemos que cambiar y es una de las
primeras principales problemas que
tenemos en viaje a marte no solamente
por las comunicaciones sino por los
cuidados médicos y por otras cuestiones
logísticas
no vamos a poder hablar y levantar el
teléfono y preguntarle a un especialista
médico
que me puedo tomar si me lo de la cabeza
tenemos que tener cuidado absolutamente
autónomos para el cuidado médico
otra cosa que nos va a ayudar este viaje
a marte es el
ver nuestro papel en el universo
nosotros vivimos en la tierra y creemos
que somos la mayor especie la más
evolucionada de todo el universo
nosotros por ejemplo aquí en sonora nos
podemos despertar un día y en la noche
podemos ver la luna en el desierto y
pensamos la distancia y pensamos que
todo el universo lo vemos alrededor de
nosotros sin embargo volviendo a la
exploración de la luna cuando la primera
misión que realmente fue alrededor de la
luna la misión apolo 8 que no aterrizó
en la luna pero fue necesaria para la
misión apolo 11 que se aterrizó en la
luna esta misión fue la primera que le
dio la vuelta a la luna y fueron los
primeros astronautas y humanos que
pudieron ver al planeta tierra desde
otro cuerpo celeste en este caso desde
nuestro satélite natural la luna y este
fue un momento de la historia que nos
cambió la cosmovisión de donde estamos y
de dónde venimos y cuál es nuestro papel
en la tierra nos hizo sentir lo
afortunados que somos y realmente que no
somos probablemente la gran especie que
pensamos que son los que vivimos en un
universo de un tamaño que ni siquiera
nos podemos imaginar
cuando neil armstrong aterrizó en la
luna y plantó su pie y dijo las frases
que todos conocemos
este es el primer paso para el hombre
pero un gran salto para la humanidad que
todos conocemos como decía todos los lo
recordamos y nos tocará vivir el viaje a
marte
cuando estemos allá y nos demos cuenta
de lo afortunados que somos tal vez
pensemos en muchas otras cosas y
nosotros estando aquí
no pensamos a veces en otros poblados
menos afortunados que nosotros como es
el caso de santos reyes yucuná en oaxaca
que es el poblado más pobre más aislado
que no tiene servicios básicos no tienen
electricidad educación salud drenaje
cosas que todos nosotros todos los días
utilizamos y ni siquiera pensamos que
los tenemos
y cuando vemos este poblado y pensamos
en la gente que vive ahí
y comparamos esto con la estación
espacial internacional o el viaje a
marte a veces es difícil hacer la
conexión entre las dos cosas pero en
realidad los astronautas que viajen a
marte y los pobladores de santo redes
circular como un ejemplo de una
población aislada tienen muchas cosas en
común
los astronautas viven en una cápsula en
un hábitat una nave espacial
completamente aislada cuando viajemos a
marte cuatro astronautas probablemente
dos hombres dos mujeres van a estar
completamente aislados de la humanidad
de la tierra de su casa no solamente de
la cuestión psicológica sino de los
servicios básicos como los pobladores de
santo reyes yucuná
algunos de nosotros que somos
apasionados del espacio tal vez estamos
un poco locos
a veces pasamos tiempo en una lata de
aluminio de tamaño humano del tamaño
aproximadamente de una sala y un comedor
de una casa mexicana
y nos ponen ahí por 30 a 45 días para
simular una misión a marte y
experimentar las cuestiones psicológicas
y las cuestiones logísticas
imaginen ustedes que están en una de
estas cápsulas con tres otras personas a
las cuales ustedes no eligieron no son
sus amigos son personas que su jefe los
eligió y que no probablemente se lleven
muy bien con ellos no hay ventanas no
hay puertas no hay comunicación en
tiempo real no hay redes sociales no hay
películas no hay streaming no pueden
levantar el teléfono para hablar con sus
amigos en tiempo real no pueden abrir la
puerta y salirse y prácticamente no hay
privacidad esto en las condiciones que
van a vivir los astronautas
por eso tienen que ser unas personas con
ciertas características una de ellas es
que tienen que cuidarse de sí mismos
pero no son médicos o muy probablemente
no sean médicos esto requiere que
desarrollamos cuestiones de inteligencia
artificial y de cuidados médicos
autónomos
los cuidados médicos autónomos requieren
ciertamente que no un médico que vaya en
la nave espacial pueda darles el mismo
cuidado médico a los astronautas como si
estuvieran en un centro médico de alta
especialidad
esto es algo que ciertamente todavía no
existe pero trabajamos día a día junto
con miles de personas ciertamente el
esfuerzo está incrementándose para
llegar a ser algo similar al viaje a la
luna que les platicaba con el medio
millón de personas
tal vez lleguemos algún día y tengamos
algo similar a jal
a la inteligencia artificial en el
vehículo espacial que nos pueda decir en
dos días te vas a enfermar tómate una
medicina hoy para que no te enfermes en
dos días es decir estamos tratando de
predecir la enfermedad en el futuro
antes de que suceda
y tenemos ciertas cosas que en el día de
hoy podemos utilizar y podemos llevar a
poblados como santos reyes yucuná o
cualquier otro poblado aislado en la
tierra
que no necesariamente un médico que
exista o que un médico que esté
físicamente en ese lugar pueda darle los
cuidados médicos a los pobladores con un
portafolio del tamaño de un portafolio
que se lleve el trabajo podemos tener
los dispositivos médicos para tomar
signos vitales para tomar muestras de
sangre simplemente con la punta del dedo
y el mismo sistema que tiene
inteligencia artificial analiza estos
parámetros y le puede dar una indicación
al paciente o tal vez una enfermera que
pueda viajar de pueblo a pueblo y si se
requiere alguna otra cuestión puede ir
entonces y viajar a la capital del país
o incluso tratar al paciente en el lugar
específico y esto es lo que tratamos de
hacer todos los días yo hay muchas otras
personas que estamos en proyectos como
estos ciertamente es que somos parte de
una de las miles de personas cientos y
miles de personas probablemente en el
futuro y es realmente honor trabajar ahí
pero es aún más un honor estar aquí con
ustedes el día de hoy muchas gracias
[Aplausos]